andrea is in Logan Utah hi Andrea how
are you I'm okay thank you I just wanted
to thank you for all you do
he's been a big blessing to me well
thank you how can I help today okay well
to cut to the chase I am recently coming
out of a marriage equality marriage and
during that time I co-signed with my
husband on some student loans and looks
really ugly twisting this whole thing is
he's he's in jail at this time and he's
unable to pay his you know his share of
the student loans so naturally because
I'm a cosigner
you know I assume the responsibility I'm
just wondering if there's any way that I
could possibly not be you know given
that given the situation and that I'm
you know I know I have kind of a not as
good of any income obviously since he's
not working and I'm trying to work that
out and everything but I was just
wondering if there's any way out of that
well your life has been an adventure
let's see what's he in jail for how long
will he be there you know I don't know
he has his sentencing next month but you
know I it's just been a real rough so
you haven't you have a divorce this
final yes and in the divorce decree you
were told or he was told to pay these
bills but he can't because he's in jail
or what
what's the divorce decree say well
that's the thing I mean it
it's it's pretty much there I'm just
waiting I'm just I talked to the bank's
about that I'm gonna stop I wouldn't
want to ask you what does your divorce
decree say about who is responsible for
these student loans yeah it's it's that
knew of a situation
it's how recent is the divorce final or
not not quite almost calling next week
but I mean the the the divorce papers
that you signed said who's responsible
for what death yes yes he would be
responsible for his student loans that's
what I'm asking and then do you have any
other debts no I do not and how much
student loan that is there so the one
that I just signed on but the smallest
one is about two thousand seven hundred
and I'm working on that and then the
next one is about thirteen thousand
okay so there's fifteen thousand seven
hundred dollars in student loan debt and
you have no debt other than your
co-signing on these correct I do not and
how many children do you have
how old are they and four quarters and
what are you doing for living how much
money you're making about a thousand
five hundred a month which is not very
much it's about two hundred and forty
eight dollars I paying toward the
student loan so no stops I'm not worried
about student loans I ask you what
you're breaking what what do you what do
you what are you doing for a living
hospital right now I work as a nurse
technician good how late yeah what's
that
how old are you I'm 32 okay all right
you have been through hell kiddo
and let's just let's lay things out on
your
strategy for your life going forward I
have a 32 year old daughter so I'm gonna
be your dad for a minute here okay
so here's what you're going to do you've
been through hell but that's in the
rearview mirror you have job one is to
take care of you and these kids student
loans are way down on the list of things
to worry about I'm not worried about
them at all right now okay you're making
$1,500 a month in Logan Utah with two
babies if you feed them and keep the
lights on and keep a roof over your head
you're doing a pretty good job kiddo
okay that's job one food lights water
shelter living on a budget and under
control that's job one I'm not worried
about these student loans you can call
them and tell them you're not paying
them right now tell them to jump in the
creek okay okay you know they may take
your tax return money at some point
later in the future but right now you
have two babies to feed you don't have
any money you're feeding the babies okay
and just don't worry about them now I do
want you to get around to getting them
paid because I got a feeling he's gonna
be in jail for a while the way this
sounds yeah yeah so but we've got it
first things first or you and the babies
you take care of you and the babies
first now we're settled okay next step
is what are we going to do to make some
more money and what is our career path
to wear when you're 42 you're making a
hundred eighteen thousand stood a teen
thousand a year somewhere along there
you're going to reach over and pay off
those student loans after you get moving
okay okay so here's what I want you to
do I want you to go get in the Financial
Peace University membership I'm gonna
give it to you as my gift okay you cost
you nothing then I want you to go that
class and I want you to get some most
people around you and you tell the
pastor at that church where I'm sending
you or the coordinator that's
coordinating that class your story so
they can come around you and make sure
you've got all the support you need
while you're going through this you got
to have family right now kid
hold on Kelly a pickup will take care of
you you call me if you need more help I
know you're scared but we're here for
you